I
the transition is made from the form of
the one or unit into that of
universality from one absolute
abstraction into the other from the
purpose of pure being for self which is
thrown off all community with others
into the sheer opposite which is thus
equally abstract being in itself
consequently the form in which
disappears is that the individual has
simply perished and the absolute
unyielding pneus of individual existence
is pulverized on the equally unrelenting
but continuous world of actuality since
it is as consciousness the unity of
itself and its opposite this downfall is
still for it its goal and realization as
also the contradiction of what was for
in essence and what is in itself essence
it experiences the double meaning
implicit in what it did that is when it
took hold of life and possessed it but
in doing so it really laid hold of death
what we discovered in the last paragraph
and Hegel laid this out in considerable
detail was that the drive or the pursuit
of pleasure as the meaning for for
consciousness of its individuality its
happiness turns out to be not only empty
in the classic sense of you know
revealing to us that it's not the
highest good or anything like that but
that there's an emptiness within it that
reveals that it simply cannot provide
the sort of fulfillment that it is that
the human subject is looking for and
instead there is this interesting
transition to the pure category and to
Hegel talked about three categories in
particular and we're going to talk about
that here and how those still pervade
this paragraph which is 364 now we're on
the other side of this equation between
pleasure and necessity and what we're
going to see is that Hagel tells us that
not only does necessity come in
inevitably in this this attempt to try
to you know work out this Gestalt of
pleasure seeking but that it cannot
actually be you might say reconciled or
processed at this point integrated would
be another way of putting it with what
is what is going on in terms of fate in
terms of necessity here in terms of
universality so you notice that we've
got this transition happening from the
one or the unit as he says to the
universality we have this this complete
shift and notice as well that this is
all happening within consciousness which
is connecting all of these together so
what what is going on here if we read
between the lines and we think about
what happened in the last paragraph
we have the one or the unit right unity
the category of unity and then we have
the category of distinction or
difference or something else coming in
winter sheet right so we have you know
einheit unterschied and then we have the
relation between both of them holding
them together even as they separate out
from each other and distinguish each
other you know against each other we
have the beziehung which is
consciousness itself and at this point
heagle continues to speak of a
contradiction of beautiful in the heart
of consciousness so I didn't put too
much else up on the board but all the
things that he's saying in this this
this passage is paragraph refer to this
and this is indeed the play of those
empty categories as the empty
essentiality that he was talking about
in the last paragraph so Hagel says we
make this transition from the form of
the one in to that of universality
pleasure into necessity from absolute
abstract from one absolute abstraction
into the other now notice that he's not
saying oh from the concrete to the
abstract because what did we discover in
looking at pleasure at least through
Hagel's eyes pleasure itself is likes
and certainty it seems like it's the
most concrete the most in your face we
can start with this because at least we
know what this is as a matter of fact
this reminds me of you know when a
sister has his character squaring off
against each other and one of them says
well how do you define pleasure and the
other guy says this is roughly
paraphrasing what are you talking about
you don't know what pleasure is so
there's that common reaction but Hagel
doesn't stop there Hagel says no
pleasure is abstract so we have abstract
being for itself we have abstract being
in itself
and he goes on and he says we have one
transition from one absolute abstraction
and to the other from the purpose of
pure being for self which is thrown off
all community with others remember even
back before this pleasure necessity
section earlier in the introductory
stuff we saw that the individuals are
threw off the the ethical community the
ethical substance the mores the laws and
said look I that stuff's great put it
aside for a minute I'm going to seek my
happiness and so the individual did that
and what comes to mind first which is
pleasure and this is this pursuit of
pure being for self it's not just enough
to enjoy one also in trying to
understand the truth of pleasure wants
to grasp one's own enjoyment in how it
takes place and when we do that we we
discover and this is something that
Plato you know brings to mind for
example in the symposium you know Plato
instead of saying don't look at
beautiful body says yeah look at them
all you want because what you're going
to realize after a while is that they
all have something in common with each
other something that exceeds the
beautiful body beauty beauty of what
well that's not quite determined at this
point but the the beauty is there for us
to take pleasure in and we can go on in
other examples but the transition is
what's important here so he says pure
being for self which threw off all
community with others into the sheer
opposite which is thus equally abstract
being in itself and we can think about
this you know what is this over here
this is this is fate this is this is
necessity we could understand this in
terms of you know physical necessity you
know you take for example you know
shooting up heroin right well you know
if you do that it's going to be
intensely pleasurable for a while then
you get addicted and now you're living a
life which is you know punctuated highs
of pleasure with a lot of pain of
different sorts and it's pretty
rare that it turns out okay for people
who become addicted to heroin right and
you can say well you know the physical
effects they work on your body and say
there's some math as well I mean look at
the before and after pictures and you
look at what happens to people who
become addicted to those sorts of things
they end up as a husk right and you said
well that's because of the effect of the
chemicals and you know there's a
physical necessity taking place far more
important than that is what we might
call the realm of social or cultural
fate or a necessity so I and now let's
put aside you know addiction to hard
drugs or stuff like that by pursuing
pleasure as the fundamental good we can
cut ourselves off from so much and it's
not just that while society doesn't like
you to pursue pleasure so you know
they're going to put a damper on you and
crush you or anything like that no the
mechanisms tend to be much more complex
and the narratives tend to be you know
more complicated than that you know I'm
reminded when thinking about this and we
could come up with all sorts of examples
along these lines of a John Cougar
Mellencamp song paper in fire you know
if you read the verses or just listen to
the song it talks about people who are
in fact trying to make their life
goodbye by pursuing pleasure and they're
doing so in a way that has to do with
other people and they even get what
they're after but it all burns up like
paper and fire and then he's got a sort
of caution in the third verse for the
young people who don't understand that
you know days of vanity can go on
forever and the grass looks greener on
the other side if we pursue it where I
end up like just finding a burnt grant
you know brown field and this is where
we arrived when we try to be that shape
of consciousness that Gestalt which is
low
creating the good locating meaning
locating the truth in in pleasure and in
the possession and the enjoyment of
pleasure so we wind up with fate over
here abstract being in itself he goes on
and he says consequently the form in
which this appears is that the
individual has simply perished and the
absolute unyielding pneus of individual
existence is pulverized on the equally
unrelenting but continuous world of
actuality that's the way we often depict
it to ourselves right the individual the
whole the whole doesn't really care
about the individual it makes it at the
individual apart and then sucks
everything out of it and then throws it
away sort of like ants in a colony I
suppose or other social insects of that
sort right that's not all that's going
on here though Hagel's say so he goes on
and he says what's the key thing binding
them together its consciousness and the
consciousness is the consciousness of an
individual it's not just consciousness
writ large in the laws the mores and the
narratives which say hey don't be
prometheus because look what happens to
that poor bastard when he steals the
fire from Zeus he winds up you know
imprisoned you know we have we have a
conflict of rights and wrongs and some
people end up on the wrong side of the
stick when it comes to who's going to
get punished for it there's that but we
can also think of it in terms of the
individual consciousness not just a
group consciousness the individual
consciousness realizes that it is being
confronted with necessity insofar as
that's the case the individual
consciousness is not completely gone
even in the woe is me for I now realize
that in taking my pleasure i set myself
up for whatever you know fate awaits me
that's still me saying all that stuff
thinking all that stuff so he goes on
and he says
since it is as consciousness the unity
of itself and its opposite this downfall
is still for it its goal and realization
now this is interesting because what
we're seeing is that there is something
inherent about the pursuit of pleasure
that leads to this downfall not just as
a consequence but as an end it's vac and
as a realization the the truth of
pleasure turns out not not to be that it
wants a hell of a lot of fun or you can
get it wherever you want just pluck it
like the grape right but rather that we
end up in the throes of necessity so he
says this is its for it for its golden
realization as also the contradiction of
what was for it essence and what is in
itself essence there isn't just a single
essence here or you might say essence is
revealing to us in this this process
this trance transition and
transformation that essence has more
than one side and one side of it the
essential turns out to be this fate so
he says it experiences the double
meaning implicit in what it did that is
when a hold of life and possessed it in
doing so it really laid hold of death
what is this very dramatic language no
Hagel is using death here to talk about
what is not living the abstraction and
we just saw that fate or necessity in
the paragraph before this is what we we
don't grasp we don't understand it just
confronts us so now what else is to be
said about that now we have to look at
the next two paragraphs
this transition of its living being into
a lifeless necessity therefore appears
to it as an inversion which is not
mediated by anything at all the
mediating agency would have to be that
in which both sides would be one where
therefore consciousness recognized one
moment in the other its purpose and
action in fate and its fate in its
purpose and action that is would
recognize its own essence in this
necessity but this unity is for this
consciousness just pleasure itself or
the simple single feeling and the
transition from the moment of this its
purpose into the moment of its true
essence is for it a sheer leap into its
antithesis for these moments are not
contained and linked together in feeling
but only in the pure self which is a
universal or thought consciousness
therefore through its experience in
which it should have found its truth has
really become a riddle to itself the
consequences of its deeds are for it not
the deeds themselves what befalls it is
for it not the experience of what it is
in itself the transition is not a mere
alteration of the form of the same
content in essence presented now as the
content in essence and again as object
or outwardly the held essence of itself
the abstract necessity therefore it has
the character of the merely negative
uncomprehending power of universality on
which individuality is smashed to pieces
what hegel is now charting out for us in
paragraph 365 is a failure a failure at
this point which is not going to remain
a failure when we move to the next
Gestalt the next shape of consciousness
in discussing you know the law of the
heart the frenzy and self conceit which
is just two paragraphs from here but in
this paragraph what we see is that
mediation doesn't take place the way
that one would hope that it would and
you know this is a great reminder by the
way that you know when people think
about the Hegelian process or Hegelian
dialectic and it's always you know
thesis antithesis synthesis you know
this nice flowing movement through the
ages and all that that's really a gross
oversimplification what we see here what
we see actually much more often what we
see here is an antithesis but it's it's
something different he's talking about
these as being and gagan because that
stuff you know not just opposed to each
other but you know set off against each
other and both of them being there you
might say it this way not to get too
deep into this that not all antithesis
are antithetical in the same way and how
is this going to occur at this point how
are we going to get a kind of blockage
which is going to require us to slip
beyond well he's talking about the
living being and this transition to
necessity as we we talked about in the
previous paragraph he says this
transition of its living being into a
lifeless necessity appears to it as an
inversion an inversion which is not
mediated by anything at all and so this
mediation here is really going to be
illusory and it's a loser II in two ways
the first is that there is no mediation
at this point they're the things are
just antithetical they are and gagan
that's the right there set off against
each other without any resolution
without any reconciliation in sight in
this at least which means that the the
person pursuing pleasure in this way is
always going to be somewhat of a
tortured individual tortured by their
own estrangement their own alienation
from themselves that's a separate
separate issue right the other is that
there is an attempt to try to find
what's going to mediate it and it turns
out to be totally inadequate to be the
mediator so what is Hagel go on and say
he says the mediating agency here's the
criteria for what would have to be a
meeting mediating agency would have to
be that in which both sides would be one
would be unified would we brought
together right we're there for
consciousness recognized one moment in
the other and the way that he talks
about this is in terms of action and
purpose so that if we want to say that
you know this this this action on the
part of individuality and the purpose of
the action somehow is in a mediation
with this other thing that that is
confronting at this whatever we're going
to construe that as that means that we
need to as he says be able to find the
purpose and the action in fate and find
the fate in the purpose and the action
and you know what would be examples of
this well you know when somebody says oh
I've understood what my my destiny is
it's to go on and save the nation right
let's take you know these are these
great you know Roman heroes of the past
you know the early republic and even
before that during during the time of
Romulus and then the Kings and there's
the recorded in these deeds of famous
men right and there's some pretty cool
stories in there
and those are people where they're
they're doing something and there's an
intention they're like think of you know
these confrontations with the other
local peoples well it's part of part of
a fate a greater thing which is the you
know Roman community you know and it's
spread across Italy kicking the Greeks
out kicking the Etruscans out conquering
the say vines conquering these people
conquering those well that is one way in
which we can identify what we're doing
with something bigger than ourselves as
we say all right there's an action
there's a purpose of the action and it
doesn't just end there there's a feat or
a destiny this this larger thing that
encompasses it now let's take something
a bit more close to I think many of us
my fate is to you know take something
that we see in many movies my fate is to
be with this particular person because
they are the one for me action right
bring roses and you know we've got the
boom box you know uh 1980s movies and
things like that purpose I'm gonna win
you back I'm going to shoot you know we
just have to take a chance together and
we'll we'll find out that we're great
people suited for each other just don't
have any sequels fate you know great
romance love conquers all whatever we
want it to be something bigger again
than the individual we can also go the
other way and say that we read this fate
into the person's purposes and actions
now why this all sounds pretty good
doesn't it why then do we not get this
why is this ruled out well what's this
section about he says this unity is for
the consciousness just pleasure itself
or the simple single feeling single
could be also translated as individual
einzelnen right and
the transition from the moment of its
purpose into the moment of its true
essence is for it a sheer leap into its
antithesis so we have a gap here we have
and ethicist and gig'em alright let's
apologize for the illegibility of that
and gagan Gazette's the set off against
each other you know opposed to each
other as an antithesis we have a leap
here things don't make sense things
can't be put together in that way there
is no mediation at this point so he says
well what does this give us he says
these moments are not contained and
linked together and feeling but only in
the pure self which is a universal or
thought consciousness therefore through
its experience in which it should have
found its truth what does it discover
instead it has become a riddle to itself
the consequences of its deeds are not
for it the deeds themselves what the
falls it is for it not the experience of
what it is in itself the transition is
not a mere alteration of the form of the
same content in essence instead he says
the abstract necessity has the character
of the merely negative merely privet you
might say uncomprehending power of
universality on which individuality is
smashed to pieces fate necessity in
terms of the one who is seeking pleasure
and remember that in terms of the one
who's seeking pleasure not necessarily
in terms of every individual whatsoever
but in terms of that particular drive
reveals itself as something that is
radically alien and opposed to that that
cannot be mediated with it and which is
going to win in the end
this is as far as the main
asian of this form of self-consciousness
goes the final moment of its existence
is the thought of the loss of itself and
necessity or the thought of itself as a
being that is absolutely alien to it
however self consciousness has in itself
survived this loss for this necessity of
pure universality is its own essence
this reflection of consciousness into
itself the knowledge that necessity is
itself is a new form of consciousness
we end this short subsection of pleasure
and necessity with paragraph 366 with
this particular shape of
self-consciousness the
self-consciousness that is focused on
pleasure as falling into this pit of
necessity where it is ground up where it
is destroyed where does smashed Hagel as
all this you know very dramatic language
with respect to it where it finds only
this alien necessity or it finds the
thought as a being how Miller's
translating faizan an essence that is
alien to trend that is that is other to
it now there's there's actually some you
know good news here in a certain respect
as they're almost always a cankle isn't
there right he gives a very takes away
with one hand but always gives you
something back but it's never the same
thing that he took away so he says this
is as far as the manifestation of this
form of self-consciousness goes this
form of self-consciousness the book
doesn't end there right we're moving
into another section so he says the
final moment of its existence is this
thought of the loss of itself in
necessity or the thought of itself as a
being that is absolutely alien to it the
pit of despair however how is it
thinking that
self consciousness remains aware of
itself going down into this pit it is
aware of that necessity it is not
completely lost in it even as it feels
that it is totally lost and destroyed in
it so he says self consciousness has in
itself survive this loss for itself it
feels as if it's lost everything
including itself in itself it is not now
this remains that this means that this
remains implicit it has to be worked out
because it's the in itself not yet the
in and for itself right but he says this
necessity of pure universality is its
own essence is its own vasil so he says
this reflection of consciousness into
itself the knowledge that necessity is
itself is what a new form of
self-consciousness and what does that
mean that means that we're now ready to
move into the analysis and the unfolding
of a new Gestalt we've finished with
this one we've gone as far as it goes
we've seen that you know pleasure can be
certainly fun but if we try to make that
the the meaning of history in reality it
fails pretty miserably just like when we
try it out with Sun certainty right that
means that now we move to something
that's a bit more complex a bit more
adequate to what human life is something
richer this is the transition point to
the law of the heart
you